Madhu, why do you care about quality?
I care about quality because without
ensuring quality care to all patients
that is patient-centric and offered in both
public and private sectors I just do not
see the TB burden coming down nor do I
see TB teaching the MTB strategy goals
of TB elimination.
So from what I hear
fundamentally quality is at the heart of
how we are going to eliminate TB. Is that fair?
That's a fair comment. I still
think that even if you offered quality
care I think the world needs to address
the social determinants better I think
that is something we cannot really get
out of, but quality improvement something
we can do right away so and every
program, public or private, can institute
quality improvement without waiting for
anything else and while we are improving
quality of care and saving lives, public
systems need to address the underlying
social determinants. Mahdu, thank
you so much for doing this. This was
fantastic.
Thank you, it's a pleasure.